so today's Friday Carly's playing a
Sunday is Carly here yet she's not no so
we were last few weeks have been crazy
we've been like this so I'm obviously
here today but tomorrow Mama's gonna
drop me off in New York she's on for
Jason Aldean and came Brown yeah
and so let's go drop me off there I'm
gonna hang out with her see her show
Buster drops the back off of the hotel I
got a fly bat in Nashville I need some
shoot some content we're headlining the
CMT tour this nice okay
there's some content for that while
we're home and Finn's you guys aren't
going to cross paths here it's like
truly know is the second time in two
weeks that we've been in Canada but not
together yeah yeah so how hard is it to
carve out time like to see each other is
that what you have to do like just kind
of go to another city and just see each
other a few hours that were you doing at
this point yeah right now it seems to be
that way you know I mean we're too weird
that manual very blessed to be busy and
very blessed to have careers that are
better on the up and that are working
and that that you have music that's
that's connecting and so yeah right now
you know we're also planning are the
weddings coming up so I think we're both
like slamming everything into these
negative these next few months and are a
couple months which kind we kind of knew
you know going in it was gonna be a
little hard but I mean it's still tough
man you know you're still she's on a 13
day run I think so if like I could have
made this happen we've gone all 13 days
and so we try not to go no more than
about a week and a half right if we can
so but yeah man just think of for
himself with yeah well I heard it's
mostly her and her mom that are planning
the wedding
yeah dude they've done everything
they've done every day I have one so I
have been involved saw me off because I
was like I don't want to be a dude it's
a god I don't want to do I just don't
want to show cuz I dudes like it's a big
moment we mean we it so fortunate both
our families are super
you know cool together tightened she's
super close to my family vice versa me
and our family and so there's little
moments that I want to make sure that we
have in there for the family right and
but for the most part I just said we
have to have an open bar and we have to
make sure that my groomsmen attire is
simple okay I was like don't go I got
some buddies we just do like like I got
like an upscale restaurant Laura you
know your white shirt yeah it's like we
get we adopted get out sir they can
serve yeah this is everything I said
we've if I start asking some of my
buddies to start getting three-piece
suits that they're gonna be like yeah
with two musicians for a wedding are you
gonna sing you guys who think we're not
no but we went very fortunate man we got
so Jay Cohen is uh oh really singing our
first dance rhythm yeah a song called
made for you that's on his new record
that uh that's pretty good make that
phone call man we were well it's funny
how it happened we were you know in the
middle of trying to figure out what song
you know and I was like is there
anything in your life that pops up and
she's like no Michael Hill me neither
and
that did a show at st. Jude with Jake
and Clint black and Randy Owen from
Alabama there's really cool man that the
show ended up becoming it was it was a
fundraiser for st. Jude okay and instead
of playing hits it became like a rider's
around there became was really cool like
Clint black played a couple really cool
album cuts you know like so that thing
that inspired Jake to play like you know
not just his big hits but a couple album
cuts and and he played made for you and
so I'm sitting next to him and Jake is
an unbelievable guitar player and singer
so it's just him and a guitar and so I
got really hear the lyrics of it and I
was like holy crap this is it you know
so I texted Carly right away and I was
like hey Jake oh and made for you she's
like what no it's like it's this song we
got it you just got here
so she heard it agreed and then I did a
show with Jake like two weeks after I
said hey man our first dance is made for
you it's gonna be made for you he's like
no way that's good then I was like don't
shoot on this chance like he was up he
was up on our bus and I was like maybe
maybe cool if you never will be that guy
that's like asking your friends come
you know Sasa a man be cool if you could
maybe yo coming and to do it and he's
like I've never been a wedding singer he
said I'm totally awesome it works out
great though so it's really cool like
he's gonna play on sing our first day
it's unbelievably talented songwriter
Emily Shackleton who co-wrote every
little thing with Carl oh yeah wrote
this beautiful song to her child his
baby boy but to his future wife oh and
it just made I just sobbed whenever I
like you know here so that's my she's
gonna play the first the mom did
Sundance and then we got somebody gonna
play the father-daughter dance so that's
our music and yeah music for the thing
but we're not going to realize let's
just let's just enjoy the day